Please welcome Matthew Dixs.
>> I'm sitting in a straight back chair and
I'm watching the greatest magic show I
have ever seen in my life. The name of
the magicians are Clara and Charlie,
ages seven and three.
They have been preparing this
performance for more than an hour. They
are moving furniture and gathering props
and making costumes and rehearsing
relentlessly. There's a table in the
middle of the room and they've put a
blanket over it and on top of the
blanket there's coins and cups and
rubber balls and an inflatable sort of
rabbit and Charlie is walking around
with a cape made of construction paper
that Claraara has taped all over his
back and they open the magic show with
Charlie saying ladies and gentlemen just
over and over and over again
and it's amazing. It's like a fantastic
magic show. The magic is atrocious.
They're like the worst m the worst
magicians you've ever seen in your life.
Like every trick is worse than the last.
There's there's the disappearing Charlie
trick where Clara takes the cape and she
holds it in front of Charlie and she
says abracadabra and Charlie runs and
hides behind the couch but he doesn't
duck. So he's just standing there
laughing when the cape falls.
And they're eating apples during the
entire performance. like big apples and
little hands and like everything's
sticky and like it's so like decidedly
less professional than it really should
be. But the worst trick is the
disappearing dime trick. Clara holds her
hand out. She's got a dime in it and she
says, "I'm going to make this vanish."
And she clenches her hand into a fist
and then tells us to close our eyes.
And so we do. And I'm wondering what
she's going to do with the dime. And it
takes a second before I realize because
she's taking the dime and she's jamming
it down my ear canal, further than
anything has ever been down my ear
before.
And after a minute, she's she says,
"Open your eyes." And she's got the
fist. And she opens it and the dime is
gone. And my wife, who is unaware of the
assault and battery that has just taken
place to the right of her, says,
"Where's the dime?" And Clara reaches
behind my ear like a magician would to
pluck it. but instead she digs deep with
her index finger and gets it out.
It's horrible and it's beautiful at the
same time. And I look at my wife Alicia
and she's laughing and she has tears in
her eyes. And I know why she has tears.
It's because she's in the moment. Like
she is in the now and she's watching
these two brilliant children do this
thing. And I am never in the moment. I
am a man like trapped between two
worlds. I am forever looking to a future
that I do not like or want. And at the
same time, I'm anchored to a past that I
can't escape.
When I look at my kids do things like
this, I cannot help but see these dark
shadows on the edges. And I can't help
but literally think as I watch them that
someday this family of four is going to
be broken. And one by one, each one of
us is going to die. And this
unforgettable moment that we're having
will one day be forgotten forever.
And I know that that is dark. Like that
is as dark as dark can be. And it's
true. But it's it's not completely black
for me. There's a little bit of hope.
There's a light because there's tears in
my eyes, too. And they're not tears for
the now. They're tears from a past. It's
a past that has made me who I am, and
it's a past that gives me hope for the
future. In the summer of 1993, I was 22
years old, and I was feeling great. My
life was finally getting started. After
high school, I had a lot of struggles,
but I was finally getting ready to go to
college. And that meant I might have a
chance at making my childhood dreams
come true. And they were two, and they
were simple. I wanted to be a school
teacher and I wanted to be a writer. And
I fought like hell to get to that point.
And then $7,000 went missing at a
McDonald's where I was managing. And
although my boss didn't think I had
stolen the money, and my boss's boss
didn't think I had taken it, we ran into
a police officer who did. And very
quickly, I was arrested for something I
didn't do. And I was put in jail. And
when I was arraigned in front of the
judge, I explained to the judge that I
was going to lose my job. So, I wasn't
going to have any money and I was going
to lose my home because my friend was
moving and I was supposed to be going to
the dorms and that wasn't going to
happen now and I would end up homeless
and I didn't have a family. I told him I
didn't have parents to support me or
anyone to take care of me. But the judge
told me that I couldn't have a
courtappointed attorney because my car,
a 1992 Toyota Tursel, was nicer than
his. his words. And so that meant I was
going to have a $25,000
legal fee, which might as well been $25
million to me. And all the things I told
the judge would happen happened. I got
fired from my job. I lost my home. I
lived in my car for weeks. And then I
caught a lucky break. Friends, people
who used to work with me at another
McDonald's, Mary and Jerry, born again
Christians, they took me in. They found
out I was homeless and said, "Come live
with us." And I I lived in a room off
their kitchen. I shared it with a guy
named Rick who spoke in tongues in his
sleep and Mary and Jerry's indoor pet
goat. It was actually the goat's room
before Rick and I came along. So, we
couldn't complain really. And when I got
there, it was okay cuz then I had a
roof. And when you have a roof, you have
an address and a phone. And that means
you can get work. And so, I got jobs. I
worked in an office during the day and I
went to work at McDonald's at night
because even though I was actually going
to be on trial for stealing money from
McDonald's, this one was owned by a man,
Andy Chung, a franchisee, and he knew I
hadn't taken the money. And so, he gave
me a job closing the store at night. I
worked 80 hours a week for more than 18
months. I barely saw the goat.
And over that time,
And over that time, I was just so angry.
I was angry at my parents for not being
there. I was angry at a police officer
and a judge who had put me in this
terrible position. But mostly, I was
just angry at the world for constantly
raining bad luck down upon me at the
moment that I thought I was going to
finally get ahead.
And then everything changed on April
19th. It was midnight and I was in
McDonald's. I was closing the store. The
doors were locked. My crew were cleaning
up and I was counting the money at the
safe. I had another $7,000 in my hand
and I was stuffing it into a deposit bag
so it could be brought to the bank the
next morning when I heard the crash. And
I knew what it was. The police had come
a week before to warn me about the three
men who were robbing restaurants in the
town. And I knew about it. My
girlfriend's McDonald's on the other
side of town had already been robbed.
And the Taco Bell that I could see
outside my drive-through window had been
robbed a week ago. And in that robbery,
they had killed someone. So, when I
heard the glass break, I knew who was
coming for me. And I made the worst
decision of my life. I took that bag
full of that money and I reached into
the back of the safe and I dropped it
down the slot that sent it to a
compartment at the bottom of the safe
that I couldn't open.
And then they were in the room with me
and they had brought my crew members,
two Haitian brothers who couldn't speak
any English, and a girl named Francis,
an 18-year-old girl who I would take to
the prom a month later because her
mother didn't trust her with anyone but
me. And they had us all lie down on this
greasy red tile floor, three men in
black shirts and black pants and white
sneakers and big black guns. And they
started to open the safe and take out
the money. And they realized very
quickly that there wasn't enough money
here, that something was wrong. And so
they grabbed me and picked me up and
they told me to open that bottom
compartment. And I told them I couldn't.
There's a there was a plaque. And I
said, "Manager can't open. Owner has a
key." And they didn't believe me. And so
they started to beat me with the guns.
And they started to kick me. And I
pleaded with them that they would
believe me that I couldn't open it. And
then I felt a gun pushed up against my
head. And I heard one of them say that
I'm going to count back from three
and then I'm going to shoot you in the
head if you don't open that box. And as
they counted back from three, I begged
this man to believe me that I could not
get the money as he counted three, two,
one. And then there was a click. Was the
loudest click in the history of the
world.
And then they laughed and I cried and
they threw me to the ground. And I tried
to crawl away cuz I couldn't talk
anymore and I couldn't breathe. And they
pulled me back and they hit me more. And
then I felt a gun press into my head and
push my face down onto that tile.
And he said, "This time there's a bullet
and I'm going to shoot you if you don't
open that box for McDonald's money. So
open the safe." And as he started to
count back from three, I felt all the
Fear and anger in me just roll over to
sadness and to regret. I was a
22year-old kid on a greasy tile floor
and I was going to die having done
nothing with my life and I would be
forgotten by everyone.
And when he hit zero, there was another
click and they laughed some more and I
just wept.
And then they were gone.
And for the next 15 years, I suffered
from post-traumatic stress disorder
until I met my wife and she told me that
I probably shouldn't wake up every night
screaming. And I said, "No, it's like my
thing. Like some people collect stamps
and some people play tennis and this is
what I do."
And she said, "No, that's not actually a
thing." And she sent me to someone and I
got a little better.
And six months after the robbery, I was
found not guilty in a court of law. And
I restarted my life. And I was
relentless. I paid off my debt. I got
myself back to college. And in 1999, I
graduated and I became an elementary
school teacher. And for the last 18
years, hundreds of kids have passed
through my classroom door. And in 2009,
I published my first novel, Something
Missing. And I've published three cents.
A long time ago, there was a boy lying
on a greasy tile floor, thinking that
his life was going to be over and he
will have accomplished nothing. And
somehow I managed to make those
childhood dreams come true.
And yet so much of me now, like all of
me now, is still lying on that tile
floor.
No matter how much success I've had in
my life,
I live with a constant ringing fear
that there will be a day not too far in
the future when I will be in those last
moments of my life and that I will feel
the same regret
that I felt that day in that McDonald's.
And so when I wake up every morning, I
wake up in fear that I will not fill
this day with enough to make that regret
go away.
I'm a I've spent my life chasing a
horizon that I cannot catch.
And so that is what I do. I fill every
day that I have with writing and with
teaching and with beautiful terrible
magic shows.
And I hope and I pray that someday
it will be enough. Thank you.